the intense dash cam video showing the
moments leading up to an alleged dui
related crash in henderson joe mohler in
the newsroom he spoke with a driving
safety expert about why this driver was
still on the road despite a past arrest
joe this crash we were talking about
left the woman who took it took this
video pretty scared as you can imagine
that and the recent deadly crash in
north las vegas have many wondering what
it takes to take a license that driver's
license away
this dramatic video is from henderson
the 8 news now i-team told you about
chase skenendorf who police say is seen
in this video driving drunk just this
past weekend the driver who could be
heard screaming was scarlett thompson i
feel like somebody who behaves that way
is most likely to have a history we
looked into whether or not the driver
had problems on the road he has a
previous reckless driving conviction but
dig deeper into the court record you'll
find conditions of his plea deal dui
school and do not get arrested for
another dui i guess we have to go by the
law no and i don't like the fact that
they're reduced sandy heverly from stop
dui says crimes like that do get reduced
for a few reasons there are times when
they originally may have been arrested
for dui and for whatever reasons
maybe the the bac didn't come back to
the level that they were hoping it would
be or there's a number of technicalities
that could take place and they are then
the cases then reduced to reckless
driving she says typically following a
dui a license is suspended despite that
mini drive anyway that's not going to
stop someone if they've got their mind
made up that they're going to drive they
will find a vehicle take a look at
saturday's deadly crash police say gary
robinson caused the crash he had several
previous trips to jail he was once
arrested for an open container charge
and driving with a suspended license
charge that doesn't stop people
heavily says a dui usually leads to a
driver's license being suspended for
about 90 days reporting the newsroom i'm
joe mohler i'll send it back to you in
the studio